mysterious and unprecedented is how
authorities have described what's
happening here since late july tons of
dead fish have been removed from the
river order which flows through poland
and germany
i have never seen such an ecological
disaster before this is probably the
worst catastrophe in the history of our
district i don't think the order has
seen anything of the scale before what's
happening is a tragedy
the cause of the mass die-off is unknown
german authorities say they found toxic
chemical substances as well as high
levels of mercury in water samples
in poland however test results weren't
consistent only trace amounts of the
poisonous metal were detected
we are probably dealing with an influx
of an external substance that must have
polluted this river
the fish seem to be drifting down river
they aren't from here they've come from
somewhere else and they have been dead
for at least a day
by thursday volunteers and anglers had
collected more than 11 tonnes of dead
fish from a 200 kilometer stretch of the
river order
environmentalists have accused
authorities of not responding quickly
enough
but poland says it has issued health
warnings
we advise residents and tourists staying
in the vicinity of the river not to
enter the water not to swim in it
the drought in europe has caused rivers
to recede biologists say low water
levels may have aggravated the
contamination and with hot dry
conditions expected to continue there
are fears more ecological disasters are
likely muhammad val al-jazeera
the royal